meantime the new york state department
of health raising a few eyebrows with
their new guidance on distributing covet
treatments which appears to prioritize
patients based on race officials writing
this quote non-white race or hispanic
latino ethnicity should be considered a
risk factor as long-standing systemic
health and social inequities have
contributed to an increased risk of
severe illness and death from covid 19.
here now to react fox news contributor
tammy bruce tammy happy new year to you
not only is discrimination based upon
race in a health care setting literally
illegal literally a violation of the
constitution but it also is also another
example of blue cities doing things that
divide us based upon race why tammy why
do they keep doing this
well because that's who they are and
they haven't changed here's what we have
to consider and this is the horrible
irony of this is that the rates of
vaccination amongst people of color
black americans in particular is lower
because understandably they have some
suspicion about the intentions of
government considering the history
especially regarding health care when it
comes to government orders and people of
color black men in particular we can
think of the tuskegee experiments as an
example the problem with this is and
everyone notices it that this is no
different than that that the government
has in the past
done made decisions based on
the color of people's skin based on
ethnicity against them it's been a
problem and when we still see it
happening in the 21st century you know
people of color aren't going to look at
this and say oh great now we're getting
the good end of the stick it's a sign
that the government has not learned any
lessons from this past and nobody wants
this everyone in new york sees that the
decisions by the government has harmed
us we have a new mayor today thank
goodness but this is for the governor
they're going to have to ask her and
everyone else when did the governor know
that this is going to be the case what
kind who made these kinds of decisions
because as you've said it's illegal and
it's harmful and it's going to cost
people their lives
here's quickly the statement on the walk
back from the new york department of
health systemic poverty which is clearly
proven to be a risk factor in
populations in new york state and
nationwide has added to the algorithm of
prioritization similar to all the risk
factors it's merely mentioned as a
factor that increases risk two things
there and then we'll move on to your
betty white story uh pivoting to poverty
nobody's seeing through that and using
the algorithm where have we heard the
blame on the algorithm before we
wouldn't be here tammy if biden had just
prioritized therapeutics along with
vaccines and mandates